bonjour les jeunes c'est 6 2 qui vous
parle je vais aujourd'hui vous donner
des conseils de séduction à votre
premier rendez vous lors de votre repas
ne lui parlait jamais d'elle uniquement
de vous ne vous intéressez pas du tout à
ce qu elle voulu hausser soir oici goût
parler de votre ex ça ça va lutter enfin
et pour finir en beauté les pieds vous
inviter et puis si vous voulez péter ou
roter n'hésitez pas à bientôt les jeunes
son amour me donne des pelles tuer la
truelle de mes yeux veux tu être ma
faubel pour la vie c'est fini entre nous
on quoi en plus sur semble pas du tout à
sa photo de profil
l'âge de glace les lois de l'univers
bonjour les jeunes c'est 6 2 qui vous
parle je suis à l'intérieur dit c'est
bon je vais vous donner quelques
conseils le séduction à votre premier
rendez-vous sentimentale pensez à avoir
une hygiène irréprochable un lit fils
ont trait à saïda tu alors penser au
moins apprend d'une douce au moins dix
jours avant votre premier rendez vous
ensuite ne vous l'avez pas les ans ça
sert à rien puisque vous allez sûrement
l'embrasser ça pue à bientôt son amour
méthode est belle tu es la trouille de
mes yeux veux tu être ma faubel pour la
ville c'est fini entre nous quoi en plus
je ressemble pas du tout à la photo de
profil
l'âge de glace les lois de l'univers
bonjour les jeunes c'est schild qui vous
parle jussieu à l'intérieur des lycées
monde s'est fait bizarre je vais vous
donner aujourd'hui les conseils de
séduction
il faut toujours surprendre une fille si
elle aime se prélasser sur une plage au
soleil invite à un voyage surprise au
groenland pour une balade anciens de
traîneaux qui l aiment la mousse au
chocolat aux frais 8 du poisson fumé et
enfin si elle adore qu'on lui fasse des
compliments ne lui en fait jamais vous
êtes sûr qu'elle se souviendra de vous
parce qu'après le rendez-vous bas vous
la raccompagne aurait pas
l'amour me donne des pelles tuer la
trouille de mesures veux tu être ma
femme aille pour la ville c'est fini
entre nous quoi en plus sur cinq pas du
tout à sa photo de profil place de glace
les lois de l'univers
bonjour les jeunes sejil 2 qui vous
parle par l'intermédiaire des lycées
bonne je vais vous donner encore un
petit conseil de séduction misez tout
sur lui bon les jeunes fait thierry par
exemple si la jeune fille ça soit fait
l'asseoir sur un coussin péteur au
moment de l'embrasser vous lui versez du
poil à gratter dans le coup et puis
comme elle sera surprise oui j'étais
d'une boule puante au visage vous verrez
elle sera manque de rien
ainsi elle est encore vivante
tout le mourre me donnes tu es belle tu
es la cruelle de mes yeux veux tu être
ma faubel pour la vie c'est fini entre
nous quoi en plus je ressemble pas du
tout à sa photo de profil
l'âge de glace les lois de l'univers
bonjour les jeunes ces signes de qui
vous parle
par l'intermédiaire des lycées - petit
conseil de séduction si vous vous
inscrivez sur un site de rencontres
soyez toujours sincère ne dit jamais de
mensonges moi par exemple j'ai dit que
j'avais 22 ans que j'étais blond aux
yeux bleus athlétique que je mesure à un
mètre 92 et quand c'est un rendez-vous
suis tombé sur une femme de 60 ans qui
avait plus dans des boules sont partout
c'est pas bien de mentir en plusieurs
connu c'était ma grand mère
l'amour me donne des belles tuer la
trouille de mes yeux veux tu être ma
faux bail pour la vie c'est fini entre
nous quoi en plus tu ressens pas du tout
à la fois pas de profit l'âge de glace
les lois de l'univers